my name is paul vandervort I'm the
writer and actor and limelight the movie
I'll do that better not suck yeah yeah
what I saw was pretty good so all right
yeah move forward and squash this let's
do it Nicky killer movie yeah I
started the idea about two years ago I
had all these crazy ideas who in the
world would be able to understand this
if they weren't in it you know when I
started writing down ideas which kind of
turned into the first draft a year ago I
shot a short with just kind of a general
idea of what I was thinking about doing
and then I spent another year further
developing the script and then using
that short and you know kind of that
momentum to fundraise with investors so
and how did you meet these investors
everywhere just knocking on doors now uh
you mostly referrals either friends
friends of friends
I moved here may two thousand eight
seven years ago I was selling cars like
in the movie and the economy tanked I
bought a house when I was 21 worth
nothing like if I were to stay and try
to work things out financially I never
would have been able to move so it was
one of those classic stories of like
throw everything in my toyota 4runner
drive to LA leave it all behind and
luckily it kind of worked out so flash
forward like five years or so you decide
I'm going to do this idea so you'd had a
number of experiences that you thought
you know what I'm gonna put them in a
scripture well I mean I just would think
about things and I'm like other people
must be going through the same these
things that I'm going through not just
in the industry but in general with what
our film talks about which is all the
different types of narcissism you know
in Hollywood but also everywhere that we
all have social media and how that's
just changing everything you know when I
moved here seven years ago to now it's
completely different is in terms of how
relevant social media is and how people
use it every day so that was a part of
you know the message in the script and
in our story and then also just the
crazy things you do you know when you're
pursuing entertainment and I just kind
of yeah I thought it would be a story
that would resonate with other
particularly artists anywhere in the
world how long did it take you to write
the script the first ref didn't take
that long when I first sat down and
started writing I finished it pretty
quickly and I've written probably 20
draft sense then Wow so the process took
about two years the first draft didn't
take very long at all I'm somebody that
mostly rights at home I completely
isolate myself and shut out the whole
world and I have to but then I write
really fast as I think and then i will
go take a break and I get ideas and I
just put the notes in my phone or write
them down but when I'm actually writing
like I just have to shut out everything
and kind of live in that world when I
very first started I just was starting
to jot down ideas and how they would fit
together to tell a story that makes
sense in a three-act structure the way
that you need to tell a story for a
movie and as I went I just kind of
developed each part i ended up just
writing sequentially and then looking at
what i had
and then trying to work that back into a
structure that works for a screenplay so
it was an interesting process probably
best book I've ever read as the famous
save the cat book Blake Schneider which
I really was just picking up for the
first time when I first started writing
this idea and I have wonderful friends
you know who've done this so much longer
than the e that are you know just
wonderful and successful and had took
the time to really advise me and listen
to my ideas and weigh in and see what
was working what wasn't working so
that's a big part of it as well as
sitting down and be like here's kind of
my synopsis and then having them you
really weigh in and honestly you know is
something that I'll just be very
grateful for always if someone didn't
have a trusted friend or maybe they're
just hesitant to show their work to
people what would you advise them on
doing like you have to when I first
started writing I was like I can't tell
anybody this because everybody's going
to take it and by the end I'm like send
it to whoever you want I don't care and
I think it's like the stronger my grasp
god on what I was trying to do the more
confident I got that like take this idea
take that log line it's gonna be
completely different than what i'm going
to do with it i would say you just have
to tell your friends you know and you
have to realize that you will have bad
ideas you know and if somebody listens
to you and they go oh like maybe rethink
it you know and if people are going oh
my god that sounds amazing then keep it
but you have to be able to handle
criticism otherwise it's just going to
be an ego project I hear about writers
who like won't change a thing and they
everybody has to be married to copy and
and I will never understand that once
the 20th draft was finished how long
before you got this location and we're
ready to shoot like what was the time
span very quickly because the last
drafts happened once the director was
hired and as we were already into
casting and we're kind of just doing
tweaks and I was very lucky that the
director had such a wonderful vision for
the film that lined up with my vision so
we got together and talked about ideas
and so between then and now it's just a
month the last draft probably month ago
and are you working with anyone else or
you're the sort of the soul you know
band behind getting all the crew
together um I've been kind of leading
the charge since I first had the idea
and now
me and James the director who is your
character in the film like what's he
like a completely self-absorbed
narcissist obsessed with social media
who will do anything to be famous and
kind of that journey of being so
connected and yet so empty and
disconnected and kind of taking the
classic story of like the kid who comes
to LA and it's like so nice but then bad
things happens I kind of the opposite
like somebody so self-absorbed and
entitled coming to LA and losing
everything and just that journey but
really using social media to explore
that because it's not realistic anymore
if you don't you know it's like even
though I was talking the director it's
like all the background in the film
should just be on their phones the whole
movie and it's still a new thing that I
don't think been fully explored
everything is just going more and more
to the internet and social media and I
think it'll continue that way at least
for now you think humans are just
hardwired to want attention like that
that it's not really narcissism it's
just sort of a heightened version of how
we already are we all want to be
validated and social media does that you
know but kind of what we talked about
the film is if there's a way to find
balance because I think everybody needs
a little bit of narcissism you know in
self esteem and confidence but so much
of like Instagram it's like it's
interesting because if I post a photo of
like something really cool i see it's
like nobody really likes it they don't
care you know if i post a selfie people
all like it and it's really caters to
that mindset that you're so wonderful
that people want to look at you how much
of the character that you play or that
are others in the film is you like which
one is you it may be not your main
character maybe it's a friend or I feel
like the whole film is pieces of me
because you know some of them are based
specifically off of like mostly one
person me or somebody else and then
others are like bits and pieces of a few
people into a character but my I'm all
over the film you know and and it's so
special to be making it now because as I
look at a character it's like I have
such an attachment to them and they mean
something very special to me so I'm like
I'm all over there you know once you're
finished with the film what's your hope
for it I just want to tell the story
that we're trying to tell you know to
make sure that what's on the paper ends
up on the screen you know James is
amazing as our director our DP is just
incredible our whole team
I'm like so lucky it's scary because
it's scary to think about going on to
another film if I don't get them again
because everybody is so wonderful and my
goal is just to honor that until like
make sure that this is as special as it
can be and to tell that story that we're
all trying to tell and you know to go to
the big festivals to get you know as big
of a sale as we can and then to
hopefully make three more right behind
it and to try to get these guys back on
Boyd and you want to be the writer
producer and actor if it's appropriate
yeah i mean i have another project i've
written already that you know I'll
polish up and see if I can lock in James
but uh yeah I mean I you know I love
acting so I think I'd probably be in
about everything that I produce so back
two years ago was there a point for you
where he said you know I'm really tired
of submitting myself and I want to do
this or was the idea of just this whole
narcissism and what people go through in
Hollywood just so attractive to you was
it a little bit of both both definitely
when I started my company my whole world
changed and all the sudden every meeting
was an opportunity to learn which I've
said before and taking that power and
that control is really wonderful and you
know then you look back in your AG man
the first couple of years I just like I
didn't waste my time because I learned
other things and I met people and had
experiences but uh but yeah you got to
just control your own life you know and
that's hard to do in this business so
making content and collaborating with
other people is completely the way to go
in my opinion from two thousand eight
till now what's one thing that a casting
director or director somebody agent sets
to you that's really stayed with you
really resonated oh my gosh um well I
think some of the comments on just how
the industry has changed you know when I
first moved here I was completely not
ready to be going out for the things I
was going out on and now you don't the
business has changed you know it's
interesting how so this is one of the
things that stuck with me is people
talking about how when they are
developing a show they bring in YouTube
stars and they bring in TV personalities
who may or may not have ever acted in
their life and that's stuck with me and
that's also relevant to like the making
of this film is you know it really is a
new air
of needing to just do it yourself and if
you have a story put it on paper and if
you have it on paper go get a finance
then partner with people and create
together you know